Masoud:
You have forty seven
minutes.
Masoud:
Stay in communication with me.
Do what you have to do.
♪♪
I will be home by tomorrow
afternoon.
Masoud:
The coast is clear.
Take care of the package.
I'm in.
Copy that.
The cops are here, you have to
get out.
Tamar:
I'm almost done.
♪♪
Masoud:
The mission is burned.
They're onto you now.
♪♪
Masoud:
I will get you out.
I'll do whatever it takes.
Tamar:
I need your help.
The police are looking for me.
Tamar:
They're questioning everyone
here.
♪♪
Faraz:
If you lie to me,
you're not gonna make it home
alive.
♪♪
If I were you, I'd get my
revenge on all of Tehran.
♪♪
Faraz:
You have to admit that. Do not
test me.
Tamar:
We're not gonna get another
chance.
♪♪
Tamar:
There's no going back now.